(intriguing music)
- Alright guys, big
day around here.
I am about to interview
President Donald J. Trump.
We are doing a sit-down,
although it's a slightly
different sit down
because he is doing
it via the phone,
the classic style
of interviewing
from an undisclosed location
but before we start,
I want to say one thing
which is that his team
made it very clear,
I can ask him
absolutely anything
nothing is off the record,
nothing is to be hidden
or not to be asked
and will I get booted
off YouTube for this?
I suppose we will find out.
So here we go, my interview
with President Donald J. Trump.
Alright, President Donald Trump.
Welcome to The Rubin Report.
- Well, thank you
very much David.
Great, great to be with you.
- So President,
what are the chances that
I don't get kicked off
Twitter and YouTube and Facebook
just for talking to you?
- Oh, I think you have
about a 10% chance.
A good solid 10%.
- (chuckles) 10% Getting
kicked off or 10% staying?
- It's... No, no, 10% staying
on actually. (Rubin laughing)
You know it's,
it's crazy.
It, this is a crazy world and
let's see what all happens.
I think they're
overplaying their hand
but we'll find out
about that, Dave.
- Yeah, so do you miss Twitter?
That seems to be
the big question
that everyone wants to know.
That was your thing.
Do you miss it at all?
- So something happened that's
I think you've seen and
it's very interesting.
I do press releases
like I used to.
You know the circle goes
round and round, right?
I do press releases and it
seems that a lot of people
are waiting for
those press releases
and if you look at the,
of all places the New York
Times did a story a week ago
about
the circulation of
what I'm saying is
essentially as big.
It's very big and the
word is getting out.
I did a couple of them today.
I like because I'm
not confined as to
number of characters but you
know the number of characters,
you don't want to keep
it too long anyway,
okay that's one thing we
all learned maybe from that.
No, I, I think, I think
we're doing very well.
With that being said,
I'll be on social media in
the not too distant future.
We're looking at
a lot of options.
We had,
a hundreds of
millions of people,
you know, if you look at,
we had 91 on one site,
we had 10 on another,
we had 36 on another,
we had Potus,
we have a lot of people and
a lot of people on Facebook
and I hear it's become
very boring to be honest
and I hear in particular
Twitter's become
very, very boring
and a lot of conservative
voices have gotten off.
Some have been thrown out and
a lot of them have gotten off
and I hear Twitter
is not doing well
and it's lost it's voice
and when I started there
like 11 or 12 years ago,
it was not a success.
I mean it was not a, I don't
know it was going to make it
but it was not a success.
It became very successful and
I think you're going to see
a lot of people are going
to be finding other,
other, there's a lot
of platforms out there.
That's what we're looking at.
Getting the right platform,
a perfect platform
and I think you'll see
something fairly soon.
- Yeah, that's great to hear
and as, as you may know
I've been talking to,
to some of your guys
about locals.com
which is the tech company
I started so we shall see.
- Good.
- So, you know, I've told
my audience many times
that one of the reasons that I,
I didn't support you in
2016 but then I did in 2020
was that I started going back
and watching old
videos of you on Oprah
and on David Letterman
and on Phil Donahue
and I realized that you
were basically saying
the exact same things 30 years
ago that you're saying now
and what that made me
wonder was sort of,
did you always, you know,
they would always ask you,
Oprah would say, "Oh, you
should run for President",
or Donahue would say it but
did you always feel that
somebody else was going to do it
and then you just got
pinned into doing it
because you didn't seem to
really want to do it actually,
you kind of wanted
somebody else to do it
from the way I read it?
- It's a great,
I've, nobody's ever asked
me the question that way
and it's very interesting.
Yeah I assumed that
somebody else would do it
because people cannot be
that stupid (Dave scoffs)
to be taken
advantage of by China
and in particular at that time
if you go back 20 or 30 years,
it was Japan was really
doing a number on us
and it's all the
same and frankly it
hasn't changed because
whether it's China, Japan,
or many others, I mean it's,
they're all taking but
China obviously right now is
the head of the pack
and I always felt
that somebody else,
nobody's ever asked it this way,
I've always felt that
somebody else would do it
and they didn't
and it went for a long time,
you know, those interviews
and one thing you
have to say David,
if nothing else
I was consistent.
- I mean it was...
- Yeah.
- I've seen it too where I,
I've seen recently a replay
of some of the statements and
they're almost identical
to what I say now
and I was right.
I was right.
We have now 30 trillion in debt.
We have a country that is just,
it's just ridiculous what's
going on in so many ways.
I'd talked about
the border even then
and people coming in
and you know, the wrong
people coming in in many cases
and you see what's
happening where the prisons
are being emptied out
in other countries
and they're coming
into our country
and I was,
yeah very consistent.
It's very interesting.
- Yeah.
When did you realize that
you were going to fully
have to say what you thought?
Because when I started going
to some of your rallies
and I'm here in
crazy Los Angeles,
I was going to the Trump
rallies in Beverly Hills
and it was a joy fest.
Like it was, it was
truly unbelievable,
I couldn't believe
it and the main thing
people would say to me when
they would come, they'd say,
"Dave, you know, I'm just
sick of being called a racist
and a homophobe and a
bigot and everything else."
And I met these people,
these were the nicest,
joyous, happiest,
decent Americans ever.
- Great people.
- But when did you realize
that you were just
going to have to sort of
walk through that fire and
take those, those labels?
- So a lot of people
think I was going to run
like for a long time.
You know they were asking me
that question 30 years ago,
as you would say and
Oprah was and Donahue was,
and they were all doing it and,
and I'd give the answer
that I doubt it because
believe it or not Dave,
I'm a very honest person
and you know, I'm not
sure that you can be
honest and be in politics, okay?
And I never really thought
I was going to do it.
A lot of people thought I was
going to do it 8 years ago,
12 years ago.
I think probably it
really hit me when
I turned down a big
extension on The Apprentice.
You know, the show was
a very big success,
I did it for 14 seasons,
can you believe it?
And then Schwarzenegger
and Mo...
- I watched, I watched
I miss Joan Rivers,
I miss Joan Rivers man.
She was, she was the best.
- Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, she wanted to come on
and they all wanted to come on.
I watch Erin
Burnett, you know now
but she would beg me
to get on the show.
She, she was on
three or four times,
she would virtually beg me
to be on, The Apprentice
and now I watch her hit
from all sides on MSD and C,
I don't watch her very much
but I see she's on there
and I assume she's as
nothing but bad but she
would beg to be on as,
as did others,
as did many others.
But the show was
a great success,
and they wanted to extend it
a lot,
like at
the highest level,
they came over to my
office and I said,
"No, I got to, I
have to do this,
I have to run for President."
And they thought I was kidding.
They didn't want to hear it.
They wanted to extend the show.
They ended up getting
Arnold Schwarzenegger
who failed badly as you
know, (Dave chuckles)
he was off in like,
a matter of minutes
and they also, during the
time they get Martha Stewart
and she failed
but we had a great success
and it was for many years
and I said, "No."
And you know,
when you turn down a primetime
show long-term extension,
it's a lot of money no
matter how rich you are,
but it's a lot of money
and a lot of prestige
and I turned them down.
The top executives
of NBC came over
and they wanted to make a deal
and I turned them down and
I guess so that was really
when I thought I
was going to do it
and then of course the famous
ride down the escalator
and that was it, Dave.
That was it.
Once I rode down the
escalator with our great
First Lady that, that
turned out to be it.
- When did you
realize how connected
the sort of mainstream
media was to the swamp?
You know, you were talking
about draining the swamp
and obviously the media
was going after you,
and you started punching back
and Republicans or Conservatives
or people on the right
usually don't punch back.
- They don't.
- Yeah, did you realize it,
was it by the time
you were President
that you fully realized
or it was really,
was it that first debate?
- No, I thought
it was bad frankly
but I never knew it was this bad
and now it's worse
than ever before.
Now it's so ridiculous I mean,
you see
where Biden gets up and says
things that nobody can believe
or doesn't say things and
they say, "Could that be FDR?"
FDR, great speaker
and you know now, now it's,
it's out of control but
I've always known
that they were shaky
but I used to get great press,
you know, before I ran for,
I guess that's probably
one of the reasons I won,
before I ran for President,
I got a lot of great press.
I was getting, I was the king.
I was getting
pressed like nobody
and you know, I did fine
but I also understood
where and how they were
functioning as much as you can.
Nobody understands the press
fully to be honest with you,
I don't care how well
you do with it but
once I announced
and when I made the first
speech in Trump Tower,
once I got down from the
escalator I will tell you,
I would say the press
turned radically different
and now they've
become very corrupt.
I mean, they're really corrupt.
It's a, it's a terrible
thing to watch.
We don't have freedom
of the press anymore,
we don't have free
press or fair press.
We have a very, very
corrupt press and,
and you don't even have
to get into the argument
although you say plenty, you,
you have strong opinions on it
but we have a very,
very corrupted media.
- Yeah, no, they're,
they're long gone.
They're activists
not journalists.
- They're gonzo.
They're gonzo.
We're doing a big one in
Ohio on Saturday night
and people are already
lined up and you know,
there's just been a great
connection to the people.
I've had a great
connection to the people
and it's amazing because
when you get virtually a
hundred percent bad press
and Fox is a whole
different ball game
from what it was too by the way,
but when you get a hundred
percent anti-press,
it's just, look you
have some really great,
great people who should
have gotten the Pulitzer,
you have people that called
Russia, Russia, Russia
exactly right.
They don't get the Pulitzer,
they give Pulitzer Prizes
to people that
were totally wrong.
Totally wrong.
It's a disgrace.
But when you have that,
and it's amazing that
even in the last election,
I got far more votes
in the last election
and did far better than I did
in the first election in 2016
and it's amazing that you can
have the press so against you,
big tech against you,
and you end up getting
75 million votes,
which is the highest
anybody's ever gotten
as a sitting President.
It's, it's pretty busy,
but what it shows you is that
the people of our
country get it.
They really get it.
It's pretty amazing.
- Yeah are, are,
you must be incredibly
psyched to get back out there
with the people
and I know you're doing some
shows with Bill O'Reilly
and the rallies are
gonna start up again.
I mean to me it's just that,
people just want to be
proud of America again.
I can't wait til they
start up rallies,
whether you're there or not
just to get people out
there and holding flags
and being proud to
be Americans again.
- Well, we're doing
a big one in Florida,
I guess it's July 3rd
and we're doing a big one
in Ohio on Saturday night
and we're, we're going
to start doing it
just to give people
some pride again.
It's not, you know, it's early
but it's not really
early because...
(beep)
You know, they want to know,
they want to have a
voice out there and
you don't get it from the media.
They don't give you a fair voice
so you have to do it a
little bit differently and
you know, in the one case,
sending out those press releases
they get onto Twitter and
they get onto Facebook
and they get on to
everything I mean it's,
it's been, that's been amazing
but the voice that
really gets out,
is the voice at the rallies
because they cover the rallies,
you know, they cover the
rallies because of ratings.
The one thing ratings
are most important, okay?
If you get great ratings,
they're going to cover you
no matter what you say and
we get a lot of coverage and,
and I think it's very important
and that's what the people want
because they love the country,
they hate open borders,
they hate, you know,
sanctuary cities protect
people that are
criminals in many cases.
I mean the sanctuary cities,
they hate, defund the police.
Think of the policies
these people have;
defund the police,
sanctuary cities,
open borders,
let anybody come into our
country criminal or not
and it's supposed
to be all wonderful
and now cancel culture
and all of the other
things you're seeing on the
school boards, right?
And they're supposed to win?
I don't, I don't believe
they can win with that and...
(beep)
Because those are
not 50% issues.
Let's,
as an example we talked
about energy, right?
During the debates,
during the campaign,
and we're energy independent
but we're not any longer.
Now we're going to have to start
buying from the Middle East
and Russia and all
these other places.
We were energy independent.
Now we're not because they
canceled a lot of deals,
canceled the pipeline,
how about canceling
the pipeline,
but letting Russia have its
pipeline to Europe and Germany
and it's just,
it's I don't believe that those
policies are anywhere near
50% but I think...
(beep)
- Yeah, I think my 10%
that you predicted about
staying on YouTube may have
just dropped to 5%, but that...
- I think you're finished.
Let me reduce it.
Yeah. (chuckles)
- That's all right.
That's all right.
Let me just ask you a
couple of other things,
'cause I want to be
respectful of your time.
Were you ever really,
were you ever really
worried about impeachment?
Because I saw you, I don't
know if you remember this,
but we actually met
briefly at Mar-a-Lago
back in December of,
I guess it was 2018
and I had seen you
speak that afternoon
at a turning point event
and it was in the midst
of the impeachment thing.
Dan Crenshaw went
on stage with you
and brought out his piece
of paper that showed,
you know, he didn't
vote for it and, but,
but everybody was saying,
"The walls are closing
in, he's freaking out."
And I saw you that
night you had no tie on,
you were relaxed,
you were laughing.
Like, were you ever
really, really worried
or even on the
second time around?
- Well they had no
proof either time.
They had no proof
and frankly,
you know, I have a lot of good
relationships in Congress,
in the Senate and in the House
and I will say this
Richard Nixon did not.
Now he also had,
you know, 300 tapes, right?
That didn't help him.
The tapes weren't
exactly positive,
they were a total disaster
but I have a lot of great
friends in Congress.
Jim Jordan and so many others.
Banks and
Debbie Lesko,
I just have so
many great friends
and I felt in the
same way in the Senate
I have a lot of great
friends in the Senate
and I didn't feel that
assuming I was innocent,
I didn't feel that they
would sail me down the river
and I, you know, I
felt very confident
and you know, you'd see
CNN where they'd say,
"He's walking in
the White House,
he's walking in his room."
And I'd be in the
Oval Office, right?
I'd be, you know, not even...
I'll never forget, I was
with a group of people.
Very, very big business
people from another country
having to do with bringing
business to this country,
but I'll never
forget it Dave where
the television was
on and CNN was saying
I was up in my bedroom, storming
the bed, (Dave chuckles)
and I'm in the Oval Office
with these business people
trying to get them
to invest in America
and they said, "Wow,
that's really dishonest."
I said, "That's what
I've been saying."
No, there's tremendous
dishonesty Dave.
Tremendous.
- Alright. Last question
for you, for now
and then I hope we get to do
this in person at some point.
- Sure. We will.
- This is,
I never, I've literally never
done this in any interview,
I've never asked the
audience to ask a question
but I thought let's try
this with President Trump
and there were many
versions of this question
which basically is,
that pretty much
everybody doesn't think
Biden is in charge.
Nobody really thinks
he's running the show.
So the question
is something to the effect of,
who do you think is
really running this thing?
Is this the Obama machine?
Is this the Clinton machine?
Is this something else?
What do you really think
is happening right now?
- I think it's a
group of people and
a lot of people say
Susan Rice and Obama
and a lot of people say
perhaps Clinton to
a lesser extent,
although she never got
along with Biden and
she's very, very angry
because she said,
why didn't you do that for her?
You know, she was saying...
(beep)
because it's, it was far easier
'cause that race was far closer
than the race we just
had, the 2020 race and
but you have people
that it's, it's a,
it's a group of people.
I don't think it's Biden frankly
and I,
you know, in many
ways I wish it were
because that's the way
it's supposed to be,
but I don't believe it is
and maybe Harris to an extent,
although I don't think
she's distinguishing herself
with her, her border
trips (Dave scoffs)
and now all of a sudden, I said,
as soon as I announced that
I'm going to the border,
I actually made a minor bet.
I said, watch what happens,
she's going to announce and
right after I announced,
as you know, she announced
that she's going down,
I guess she's going
tomorrow or something
but she would have
never gone to the border
and I'm going next week.
So,
I think it's just
a group of people.
I mean, think of it
when he signed those 17
declarations,
special orders,
presidential orders,
he signed them
and he didn't
really seem to know
what the hell he was signing.
- No, he didn't.
- And when you think of them,
they were all sitting
there waiting to be signed
and they were radical.
They were radical.
They were Bernie Sanders
would have never asked
for most of the things
that he is signing.
This is far worse than
Bernie Sanders ever imagined
and it's pretty amazing.
So, a lot of people ask
that group, who is it?
It's really, I think
it's a group of people
and you know, the same names
but it's a group of people
and they get together and
this is what they want to do
and they're destroying
our country.
Really destroying our country.
- Last question then I
promise I'll let you go.
What does President
Trump do for fun?
You're about to hit the weekend,
it's the summer's starting,
what are you doing for fun
these days besides golfing,
I know you're golfing?
- Well, I do,
I, I try and get to play golf
because it keeps me
a little bit busy
and a little bit of
exercise and it's good and,
and I exercise a little bit,
but what I really do is work.
I mean, I work, I'm
running a business now
and very importantly,
I'm very much involved
in the endorsements,
you know, our endorsements
have meant so much.
If I endorse somebody, they win.
Almost, almost a hundred
percent of the time
and a lot of senators and
congressmen and many others,
We just won in North
Carolina head of the party
and we won in Georgia
head of the party
and we won in Texas,
as you know, and
Louisiana.
Congress and,
and you know just
the endorsements.
I think it's 228 in two
over the last fairly
short period of time.
Two hundred, think of that.
- Wow!
- 228 in two.
So they're coming
from me at Ohio,
we have a good guy
in Ohio running,
two good guys
running for Congress
and we have a lot of
good people running.
So I've done, I've
done a lot of that,
we're having a lot of meetings
with people that
want the endorsement.
We're trying to get people
that you would like
in there, Dave.
- I'm glad to hear it.
Well, Mr. President I really
appreciate you taking the time
and enjoy the weekend and I
hope we can connect again.
- We will and thank
you very much.
You've done a great job.
Thanks Dave.
- Thanks.
Take care.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist
and if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.